we are engaged in a serious discussion
right now in washington as to how to
right-size our intelligence
apparatus once bitten twice shy mep's
held talks with u.s senator chris murphy
in brussels to work out their
differences over the nsa spying
allegations since julius caesar
liked
to take over and always parliaments and
other carriage people have to stop there
to create balance and that we have now
such a debate within parliaments and
between parliaments makes me confident
that we will overcome this crisis
murphy continued the damage control to
keep the eu us free trade agreement on
track as well as sensitive data transfer
deals it seems to have worked as the
european commission announced that all
deals would be honored but warned the
u.s is treading on thin ice
european fishermen are keen to get back
into the waters off the coast of morocco
after an agreement ran out in 2011. one
of the eu's biggest international
fishing deals with morocco has been
subject to much controversy over the
disputed territory of western sahara
occupied since 1975. though a majority
of meps approved the new deal some felt
the rights of the saharawi people had
been overlooked the eu should absolutely
respect
the natural resources of an occupied
people it belongs to that people so we
can't really negotiate and pay an
occupying power to access to those
resources i agree with what the western
sahara people are saying in their
statements and they're calling this
theft
and that is what it is
it now faces the gauntlet of the plenary
vote in december
noise pollution is the new frontier in
the battle for city dwellers health
excessive noise levels can lead to poor
sleep and heart attacks according to the
world health organization even the
levels of deafness arising more than 200
million eu citizens living in cities
could be affected which is why meps
passed new rules limiting the noise
emission levels for cars fans buses and
lorries if it passes a plenary vote in
december vehicles will have to cut their
volume within one or two years time